my name is Tim Murray I'm from the
Android performance team and I'm gonna
talk about systrace which we were to
talked about a bit earlier with the
system tracing and Android studio but
I'm going to talk more about the old
style of looking at traces as well as
what you actually do with a trace so
what are the big performance goals for a
game they're really two big ones number
one you need to get the gameplay fast
the user has to wait 10 20 30 seconds to
launch a game then you know they're
gonna they're gonna quit they're not
gonna be happy with your game they're
gonna find another game the other thing
is you need to maintain interactivity
during gameplay it's great if you get
some gameplay fast but if the gameplay
is super janky dropping frames all over
the place it's really bad
so the problem is mobile devices are
really complicated you know you look at
a current flagship phone and it's an 8
core CPU with heterogeneous CPU cores
and there's a giant GPU and your flash
performance is totally different than
what you would expect on a PC there's a
lot going on you really can't assume
anything about how your code runs I've
been looking at performance for years
now I can't predict how Cobra no one
should have seen how their code runs so
that's why we have systrace it shows you
what actually is running it is sort of
truth like capital P truth assist ray
says something ran at a certain time it
ran at a certain time you cannot lie to
it you cannot trick it it's outputting
events from the kernel directly whatever
systrace says is happening is actually
happening which makes it really great
the other great thing about it because
it's so low level the overhead is
basically zero
we will just turn on systrace and let it
stream into a buffer like a in memory
buffer so you know you record you can
get the last 10 or 20 seconds out of it
it has no measurable overhead its sub 1%
so we do that and we find a ton of
performance bugs that way it's great so
first of all let's talk about how to
take a trace and I'm gonna not talk
about the Android studio side of things
because we already talked about that I'm
gonna talk about the two other ways we
have to take a trace so first of all
most of the tools for tracing other than
Android studio exist in this open source
project called catapult it's maintained
by people from the Android team and the
chrome team and it lives on github so
you grab the git repo for catapult and
you end up with a sister a spy thon
binary in that directory catapults
distress baton systrace and that's kind
of the the main shell to using systrace
if you want to take a trace in the
command line essentially you run that
and you pass a bunch of they're called
tags to assist trace and this will
determine the kind of output you get in
the trace so here it's going to take a
trace containing scheduler information
so like exactly what the scheduler is
doing at any given time CPU frequency
and CPU idle information some Android
activity manager and window manager
information then a bunch of information
about the graphics stack and then a
bunch more things well input is useful
for game devs but the other ones aren't
too useful input shows you when actual
touch event happens so that's really
useful for game developers the last
three options are not tags so - B is the
buffer size the buffer size determines
how much you can actually record in a
trace so it's a per CPU ring buffer in
so here this is in kilobytes so on this
device I get 16 Meg's
per CPU generally you know 10 Meg's or
so per CPU is totally fun on a high-end
device it kind of depends how much
context switching you're doing because
that is probably what what occupies the
most space most of the time you can get
about I would say it's about 1 Meg gets
you about 2 seconds of a trace so you
can record a pretty long trace with this
- T is an optional argument it tells you
how long to record the trace for if you
don't pass - T you just press ENTER to
stop the trace and then - o is where to
write the trace if you don't pass that
show it defaults to trace dot html'
which is fine but also very annoying
when you start taking hundreds of traces
and they're all named trace on HTML so
here's the cool new thing in Android P
which is actually incredibly useful so
it's really annoying to have to have
your phone plugged in to take a trace
and most does this trace actually lives
on the device these trace binary is
basically just talking to device ID
stuff so in Android P we made it so you
can take a trace from the device the
great thing about this is that you turn
on developer options and you get this
quick settings tile once you turn it on
you can start taking a trace and it will
stream into that in memory buffer so you
can turn on a trace it has super low
overhead so you can just leave it on to
do your thing and play your game and
then you see like hey that seemed like
it took a long time or hey I just
dropped a bunch of frames you pull down
quick settings stop the trace and you've
just captured exactly what the problem
is and you can just pull it off or email
it to yourself and see what's going on
it will pop up a dialog that allows you
to email it or share it to drive or
dropbox or whatever it's also saved to
the device in data local traces if you
do want to pull it off the
ATB the only special thing about the the
system tracing like quick settings that
approach is that they are compressed on
the device so you have to do some
post-processing with systrace and
catapult and I think and rescue is
adding support for this soon so you can
import to Android studio as well but you
process with the firm file argument and
you will get a trace out of it a normal
HTML trace so okay you got a trace what
do you do with a trace because it's kind
of a lot let's go through a pretty
simple one and then we'll go through
some gaming ones so I don't know how
legible this is this trace doesn't
really present well but essentially you
have a big timeline view here so I took
a trace of application startup I think
calculators start up and at the top
there's some basic information about the
overall state of the device this
interactions and alert stuff the kernel
line is where we can see what is
actually running on every CPU core at
any particular time and then we start
getting into a lot of per thread
information below that well that will go
into more detail about in a moment so
there's a lot more info than fits on the
screen so it does scroll up and down so
make sure you scroll you also can
navigate around the trace with WASD so
Andy to move left and right and W and s
to zoom in and out you also have this
palette this floating palette that's
that the upper right hand that contains
four tools the first tool is the pointer
the pointer lets you click stuff in the
trace and see what it is so here I
clicked one of the calculator time
slices and I now get more information
about that particular instance that it
was running
and the bottom half of screen so I can
see here's its PID here's the tid here's
the priority here's how long it was
actually running on the on the CPU so
you will use the pointer a lot the other
thing you can do if a pointer is you can
select a bunch of stuff you can just
draw a rectangle and after you draw the
rectangle you get an aggregate view so
you can look and see like what was
running during this time and you can
sort these and you know the normal stuff
that you would expect the fourth tool on
here is called I think the ruler but
essentially it is it allows you to mark
a section of the trace and you highlight
it and you can scroll up and down the
the trace view and that highlight will
remain so if you know like I've dropped
a frame around here I need to go look
around the rest of the trace to see
what's going on you can highlight that
and scroll up and down and know exactly
where you are the second and third
things on the palette are a panning tool
and a zooming tool but they're
equivalent to the Toit's D so you can
use the pallet tools if you want you can
use huazi if you want it doesn't really
matter so if we scroll down we can see
per thread information and we can see
information about each threads current
state so the first thing that you'll see
and it's hard to read and I apologize I
have an errant I do have an arrow so
there's this stack of of boxes so
essentially the trace sections for a
given thread are a stack so you'll say
like trace begin section activity start
and then something else will say trace
begin session inflate for you know
inflated view and so they appear as a
stack in the trace the other thing about
that is at least as important for
reading a trace is the
kind of multicolored bar above each
thread and you can kind of see it it's
hard to see but that tells you
information about the state of the
thread at any given time oh you can see
it in more detail there so you can see
there we've got a bunch of green
sections we've got some orange section
we've got some red we've got some blue
and sections where it's just not colored
so yeah there's some green and if you
actually click that that green bar it
will tell you that it was running and it
will tell you how long was running and
which CP it was running on so you can
track your threads progress through the
system that way you can see okay it was
running here for this time and then it
was blocked on something else and then
it woke up and figure out what's going
on there so the different colors are
there five colors number one is green it
just means the thread isn't running it's
currently running on a CPU you know it's
actually making progress during that
time the only thing that could run when
a thread is in the running state is an
interrupt and that last you know stub
microsecond most of the time so if your
thread is running it's actually on the
CPU doing work if it's runnable that can
mean one of two things a thread will
become runnable when it's been sleeping
and something wakes it up or if your
thread is just like let's say you have a
spin loop just while one do nothing
eventually the scheduler will say okay
you've you've exceeded the amount of CPU
time you can have right now I'm going to
D schedule you and that's something else
run then your thread will be made
runnable and that it is it could be
running there's nothing blocking it from
running but the scheduler has not
selected it to run the third state is
sleeping sleeping just means there's no
work for this to do so it's
running usually means you're blocked on
like if you expect that your thread
should be running but you see it's
sleeping it's probably actually blocked
on a mutex somewhere because lock
contention in userspace does show up as
sleeping the last two are kinds of sleep
inside the kernel the orange is
uninterruptible sleep in block IO which
means you are waiting on disk so if you
see that a lot it means you are loading
a ton of data from disk and maybe you
shouldn't do that the last one
red is uninterruptible sleep this means
you are blocked somewhere else in the
kernel it's probably not IO it's
probably related to memory management
because we do see that the vast majority
of time and uninterruptible sleep is
actually because of memory management
and so a kind of easy quick thing that I
do as the first part of reading any
trace is you can select all of these
bars above a thread and get an aggregate
view so here I can see that this
particular thread was sleeping for 12
milliseconds is runnable for you know
0.6 milliseconds running for 3.1 you
know it looks it looks totally normal
totally fun but you can use this to get
a sense of where your bottlenecks may be
if you are if your thread is always
running and you're still not meeting
your performance targets you're probably
CPU bound that's probably a good bet if
you see that your thread is sleeping and
never running maybe there's some lock
contention maybe you're waiting on GPU
activity it's not your the bottleneck is
not that the CPU for that thread the
bottleneck is somewhere else if you're
seeing a ton of block i/o then you're
probably reading too much from the disk
at any given time and the thread can't
make progress because it's waiting for
dead from the disk so that's kind of a
good first check for where your
bottlenecks maybe
one other really helpful thing here yeah
I didn't era up at the very top this
interactions and alerts area it's really
hard to read but you can actually see
when the user touched the screen this
input thing so you can tell like when
you have a trace and you know I tap the
screen once and something happened and
it was slow this gives you a really good
way to orient yourself in the trace you
can tell okay well this is the bad
behavior must be around here so one of
the most important things to do with the
trace is to add your own try sections
you can debug a lot of issues without
having your own try sections where you
as the app developer know what your app
is trying to do but if you add your own
trace sections life gets so much easier
it's really five to ten times faster to
debug if you have your own trace
sections so from Java you include this
package it's traced up against session
and trace that end section the only
thing you have to do is because it is a
stack you need to actually make sure
that every begins section has an end
section otherwise this trace the trace
gets really weird and it's bad and you
won't like it
but of course nobody in here really
cares that much about Java so for the
NDK you include Android trace that h/h
race begins section a trace end section
and I believe that is supported on API
23 and up so when you actually want to
take a nap trace all you have to do is
you take a trace you add dash a and your
package name and that will turn on app
tracing for your app and you will just
get results you like there is a trace
section that I added to a random app at
one point and it just shows up as any
other trace section but it's really good
for you know when you say you're loading
something or waiting on network
you know semantically what your app is
attempting to do you can express that
information in the trace and combined
with everything the system thinks is
going on you can get a much better view
of how your app performs
okay so game traces because that's why
we're here
let's look at a couple actual game
traces so just out of curiosity how many
people in here use unity okay pretty
large number what about unreal okay and
what about custom engine it's not unity
around okay cool so I took two traces
each from two popular games I like
current top twenty maybe and I
anonymized them to not kind of you know
put them on edge and first uses a custom
image in the second is a Unity game so
let's look at that first one so this is
app startup and I don't have my notes
and that's really annoying so this is
what it looks like when we after I took
the trace I figured out my pixel to
excel running key and so I open it up
and I can see this is so this was
launching a game so at some point here I
click the screen and I think you can see
it up at the very top there's that that
one place where the second row on in the
interactions section is lit up and that
is where I actually touched the screen
so I started this game and I wanted to
see you know is it fast is it good and
it took a few seconds it wasn't too bad
but you know I thought it could probably
be better so here's the actual startup
section for a game and it looks a little
weird because the UI thread is
it's called the UI thread and catapult
it's actually just the main thread is
the first thread so that starts up first
that's where app code usually runs the
UI thread just kind of goes idle for a
second in the middle they're like
actually yeah it's 1.4 ish seconds it
just doesn't run anything it's asleep
it's not waiting on anything I looked at
other threads nothing else is running
that's weird so you know if you look at
what else is running on the system it's
actually like it doesn't look it might
not look that idle it's pretty idle like
there's some stuff running at the
beginning of that time as probably like
rendering the transition to like draw
the window for the app but by the end
like nothing's running that's just kind
of waiting so we can go and see what
actually woke up the app and here I've
zoomed in to the very edge of that 1.4
second time and there's a tiny little
blue block at the end of that where that
main thread becomes runnable and here I
can see waken from tid 0 and so wake up
from tid tells you what thread made
something runnable which is really great
because you can actually get into
causation you can say this thread caused
this other thing to happen and you know
it's it's real it's true but tid 0 means
it's an interrupt and that's really
weird because apps usually don't see
interrupts directly the only interrupt
they ever really see is a timer
interrupt but let's just be careful and
sure and scroll up and look and yeah
during the I don't know 20 or 30
milliseconds before there's nothing
really running and we don't have
interrupt latency of 20 or 30
milliseconds that meet that be wild so I
kind of wonder if the app is sleeping
for 1.4 seconds
I think it's possible this wouldn't show
up on a profiler because you wouldn't
see sleep and a profiler but it really
does look like the
just sleeping during app startup so
let's go into the next try so this is
gameplay and gameplay here it has some
load screens kind of in the middle and I
wondered what was happening during that
time so the thing about gameplay and why
I still use catapult instead of Android
studio catapult will show you every
process on the system which is a ton of
data but it will also show you things
like surface flinger and surface flinger
is great and if you have no idea what
I'm talking about when I say surface
flinger let's talk about how a frame
actually makes it to the display on
Android so what is the basic lifecycle
of a frame number one apps will render a
frame so your your game will render a
frame and it will send a message to
surface flinger saying I have I have a
frame ready for you to display surface
flinger will wake up every like a 60
Hertz I guess and figure out which apps
are visible and it will build a list of
all the frames to be combined into a
form that the underlying hardware can
deal with so that list makes its way to
a vendor driver and vendor hardware
called the harbor composer and it will
take like maybe you have the status bar
up or the home and back buttons and all
of that will get overlaid and turn into
one frame buffer and that final frame
will be sensitive to the display the
great thing here is that surface flinger
tracks every app and every frame so if
we look at surface flinger state we can
see exactly what is arriving when from
any particular application so let's go
back and look at game play and look at
surface flinger so here we have this
line this surface view row and it's a
counter
so the surface view is triple buffered
so you either have zero frames pending
or one or two frames and you can see
it's usually bouncing around which means
we are getting frames from the app but
again there's a gap here and it's about
700 milliseconds and the game does do
something with load screens so let's go
see what the app is doing because this
is probably a load screen and here yeah
we have this long 700 millisecond on
draw frame section and if we look and
see what's actually happening yeah it's
running for about what is that 190
milliseconds and sleeping for five
hundred odd milliseconds so it's waiting
on other work that happen now there are
these other two threads nearby that seem
to be doing work what's up with them
well they're running and sleeping and
runnable for some of it so I let's say
said okay yeah so if you actually look
at what these thread sections are it is
they're tagged with IO MX which I know
from other Android things is sound stuff
so I think what's actually happening
here is the game is pausing it's loading
or pausing you know displaying frames in
order to lure load more sounds but you
can see kind of before this big loading
section there's a lot of free CPU cycles
like the game is not keeping the device
that dizzy this load screen can probably
be fixed like removed completely just by
moving a lot of this loading ahead of
time to overlap with actual gameplay
because this there's enough CPU time to
do it so that's the kind of stuff you
can get out of systrace in kind of less
graphically intensive games now let's
look at a really graphically intensive
game so this one uses unity as well and
let's see I think I had
i level start here and then we have
actual gameplay next so for my level
start trace this is what I see when I
first open it up and you can see the
surface view in the center there and it
does have a big chunk where surface
planer is not displaying anything
because no friends are really arriving
from the game and if we actually trace
from like highlight from where frames
are being consistently delivered in
other words before I started the level 2
when they are being consistently
delivered again that's probably after
the game is really displaying stuff it's
about 5.7 seconds it's pretty long as a
as a player to see that so let's go see
what the game is actually doing so here
is the unity main thread and the unity
main thread if you look at unity apps
you're gonna be looking at the in demand
thread a whole lot but you can see it is
not super busy which is weird and not
great so what is it actually doing well
it's running for where's it 3.1 seconds
and it's sleeping for 2.5 seconds so
what's actually happening during this
sleep so if we zoom in a lot and now
we're looking at a three hundred
millisecond period that you like I saw
this 300 millisecond pattern repeat kind
of consistently throughout this unity
main section you see that it runs for a
bit and then goes to sleep and runs for
bit and goes to sleep and repeat and it
looks really periodic it looks like it's
happening on frame boundaries so let's
see what's actually waking it up so once
again we can zoom in and there's a tiny
little blue bar that is probably not
visible from this but we can see the
wake up from tid
three one five two six which is
something so we can go scroll to the top
of the the trace now and figure out what
that is
hey it's the unity choreographer thread
so what I think is happening here is
that the game is running some unity
script and in that unity script they're
saying like they're trying to be be nice
and not like block rendering and saying
wait until next frame but this is
causing their load times to suffer a lot
there's probably a good one and a half
two seconds that get back by not doing
this during the actual load just because
there is so much free time on that
thread and that is the that is the
bottleneck for the load here there's
actually very little IO done here one of
the things we see in general on Android
is that you're generally not IO bound
especially on high-end devices low-end
devices like really low-end device is
very different but if you're talking mid
or high-end in the past few years
flash performance has increased
dramatically to the point that it's
faster than a lot of desktop machines
and you're not that I Oh bound knows the
time the biggest bottleneck is
definitely the CPU and that's what we
see like even in this very graphically
intensive game
it's bottleneck by the CPU let's look at
gameplay because there's some
interesting stuff there too so once
again there's the the surface view and
you can see it's kind of taking back and
forth in the middle there and overall it
looks pretty good I have very few
complaints about this but I can always
be pretty commit picky so let's find
something that is wrong so it did drop a
frame in the middle here there is a
place where it should have rendered a
friend and it just didn't
like no frame was ready for surface
flinger so the app probably did not
complete a frame on time so let's scroll
down and see what happened in the app to
make it not complete a frame on time so
here is the unity GFX device three which
is actually dispatching the render calls
it looks like at one point it just
skipped so it just missed like something
missed a deadline somewhere and it
decided hey just drop the frame we're
not gonna make it so let's look at the
Unity main thread and see what's going
on
aha there is the kind of smoking gun
immediately before that dropped frame
from the unity GFX device we see a bunch
of i/o on the unity main thread that's a
little weird I wonder why that happened
but then I scroll up and realized that
is exactly when I touched the screen to
trigger some special thing in the game
so my guess is that I pressed the button
in the game there was something on the
disk that was not loaded and even though
our just throughput is really high it's
still disk latency so it takes a while
for you know even if it was 20 bytes it
will still take a while to get those 20
bytes off of disk that blocked the unity
main thread which in turn caused the
unity GFX the device thread to not
render a frame and that was seen as a
frame drop but overall this is actually
a pretty good game it's running pretty
close to you know a solid thirty Phipps
I think but it is actually you know
maintaining it and working really well
but you know there's always something
you can improve with performance you you
can always be harsher on yourself
but that's why that's kind of the data
we get out of systrace it's exactly what
happened and it allows you to tie it
together across the system to figure out
what actually went wrong and coupled
with the new support and Android P for
triggering a trace on device
it's easier than ever to actually I'd
like spots performance issues and figure
out what's going on so yeah I guess
questions you just mentioned that most
of the games are not IO bound right yeah
so basically it's true when the assets
are uncompressed but the apk is
compressed itself of course you can
store some of the things without this
deflate compression there but in that
case the size is going to probably
bypass the hundred megabyte limit yeah
so if you want to read 20 bytes from the
disk it's not like reading 20 bytes from
the disk we have to read a whole block
of a zip compressed file then decompress
it and then you have access to these 20
bytes and that actually is something
which you probably can't even solve with
the higher speeds of the flesh sure but
with the flash I mean even the latency
is still poor compared to you know it's
not like you know spinning disk poor but
compared to something that's already a
memory it's it's dramatically higher and
you're always going to read some fixed
amount like there's a I forgot the
minimum granularity you can read from
the flashes but you're always going to
read some block size from the flash so
it doesn't really matter if you have 4k
to read or you know three bytes to read
you're gonna read the same amount of
data yeah there are multiple layers of
cache in everywhere so we have to
invalidate all the caches then relief
from the flash have it loaded into the
cache of the flash and then throw the
file levels do you think it makes sense
to store more assets uncompressed in
order to reduce the whole overhead so
sorry so talking from the perspective is
like on iOS the assets are stored on
compress of the device right and that
could be one of the reasons why
the loading performance or the
performance when you're loading next
level sounds like that is much higher
because you don't have to uncompress
itself so I don't actually think that's
the the reason for the difference in
like loading performance it looks pretty
much like the difference in
single-threaded cpu performance it
matches pretty closely with the
difference in single threaded CPU
performance what we see I mean
especially in unity apps is that now you
do have some five six or something like
that are still primarily single threaded
especially around load times and there's
AP bound on Android I bet they're still
probably CPU bound a lot of the time on
iOS iOS has generally has higher single
threaded CPU performance so load times
are better so more multi-threading I
mean you know we've got eight core
devices that are pretty common and
they're kind of mid and high in demand
right now more multi-threading is is
better essentially right but then you
get into power and thermal issues you do
but you to some extent yeah I mean the
CPU is the the dominant power consumer
on the system it's not the display it's
not the GPU it's the CPU so you do have
to be careful with CPU power consumption